[Music]
thank you for coming to this session my
name is Ray I'm a developer advocate for
Google cloud platform and one of the
things I love to do is to bring some of
our best technologies to developers over
the world especially Java developers
cause having a Java developer for a long
time it's my go-to language of choice
and yeah it's a it's also a great and
vibrant community and I love to you you
know bring some of the things that we
have to show you another thing I like to
do because of this is that I'd like to
make sure that we have really good
experiences for Java developers to use
Google cloud platform and so I work with
a lot of the teams internally like for
functions for App Engine for
you know cloud run and stuff like that
to make sure that we have a pretty good
awesome experience here as well as the
API services and stuff like that and
because of that I also helped introduce
and kick-started a project called spring
cloud GCP and it is a idiomatic approach
to help you to boost up your spring
application and consume some of the
Google cloud services very idiomatically
and easily if you have any questions any
feedback please let me know on Twitter
Saturn ism and or if you want to see and
find more information you can go to my
site which is sudden isn't that me and I
only have about four slides for this
session and we are about 75% through and
let me show you the last slide and thank
you for being here skinny so I'm just
gonna jump into it and to show you what
we can do I say experience from my
experience and developing for GCP
perspective for a Java developer okay so
one of the project I mentioned was
spring cloud GCP not but you'll see a
show of hands how many people here are
Java developers using Java language
avian language you see everyone good
you're in the right room so am i how
many of you are using spring and spring
but-- majority of you yeah that's what I
expect and if you haven't checked this
out please please - we basically wanted
to make sure that you know from a spring
developers perspective you can use some
of the spring abstractions and spring
layers that you're accustomed to and
being able to use some of our API
services now the reason for it is a
couple folks number one is that it's
gonna be a lot easier for you to get
started right so you
your framework you know how to use those
things and you can just change out some
implementations as some starters as some
other configuration and you're right
into the Google cloud services the other
part of it is that if you have an
existing application that you want to
migrate right there are some different
approaches and one of them is maybe that
you want to just microwave a VM so you
put a VM into Google Cloud and now
you're still using the traditional
databases and stuff like that but if you
want to change and you know gain some
velocity and being able to adopt some of
the services you have two choices you
either use the API which then you're a
tightly coupled suit to the API itself
or you have some kind of abstraction
layer that you can be a little bit more
portable so that you know if you want to
change out the implementation in the
future
you also can write so check this check
this project out so we have integration
for like spinner and data store with
spring data so you can use basic ORM and
data repositories to access data we have
logging and tracing integrations
directly into the spring framework as
well and pops up and much much more
okay I'm going to show you some of these
things today but most importantly I'm
going to after we bootstrapping
application we're going to continue rise
it we're gonna deploy into communities
and we're gonna go through some of the
best practices or things that you have
to watch out for when you are actually
deploying applications into a kubernetes
environment okay so without further ado
I'm gonna get started I have no backup
for this it's gonna be a straight shot
from nothing to something I hope that
works so it's either gonna be okay or
it's gonna be horribly wrong okay so
let's let's go so for this demo what I'm
gonna do is just go to start that screen
IO to bootstrap my new project I'm gonna
use Kotlin for this because you know for
Java for JVM you can run any jvm
languages on google cloud of course so
with App Engine you can do the JVM stuff
you can do cutland groovy Scala or use
Java language itself I'm going to make a
word a jar package in here and gonna use
Java 8 and of course in this
bootstrapping you can also add different
capabilities to your application now the
important thing here that I'm adding
here is the GCP support so by adding
this we're gonna pull in some of the
auto configurations into my project and
that's gonna make my application work
with some other Google cloud services ok
so go ahead and download this and unpack
it and open this
my intellij plugging here and ide and
we'll see what happens next
yeah yeah where's my IntelliJ that's the
there's this you went to the wrong
window that's weird okay so let me just
synchronize this project a little bit
just making sure that this is actually
the application we just created
okay and let me just go ahead and go to
the presentation mode - so I think I can
enter presentation mode so you can
hopefully see all the code a lot easier
so we have a application here that has
nothing of course it's gonna start up
and listen on port 8080 and that's
pretty much it so the first thing we're
gonna do is to add some capability to
store data now we have of course many
different ways for you to store data we
have you know cloud sequel for you to do
our TMS with put my sequel or Postgres
we have cloud spanner which is say you
know globally distributed database for
our DNA our DBMS as well or we can also
use datastore which is a no sequel
datastore that's document oriented you
don't need schemas you can just like say
I need datastore and you start putting
data into it so for this demo I'm just
gonna use the data store stuff right so
the easiest things for me to do is to
add this router for cloud datastore so
we have a shortcut here for the for the
dependency and what this will pull in is
spring data and a few other components
and also add the data store abstraction
layer on top of this what that means is
that you can actually go ahead and
create a new Pocho and you can annotate
it just like you do with the traditional
database with JPA it's gonna be very
similar here so what I'm gonna do is
just to create a new class here called
person I'm using Collin here so you know
rather than you know using all the
getters and setters I can just create a
data class here and it's gonna have two
attributes it's gonna have an ID which
I'm gonna change the type to long
because in theorist what we can auto
generate the ID for you and we can go
ahead and just mark it as an ID now
notice how the ID annotation is here
this is actually the regular spring
annotation for a primary key and for the
data class here we can just go ahead and
make an entity and this entity is
special for data store this marks it as
a datastore entity so we know how to map
it to our back-end services okay and
then we can use the spring data
repositories for CRE
in also pagination what that means is
that I can create a new interface here I
can call it personal repository and I
can go and extend the the interface
serial code restore repository this one
and I think just give it a to me and
type which is gonna be person and the ID
type which is gonna be long and that's
it that's all you need to do and you can
start using this repository spring and
our frameworks will automatically
implement this interface for you
so you can go ahead and use it to store
data we'll go a little bit further we're
going to add use the sprint eight
arrests and notation here which means
that we can actually expose this entire
repository as a restful service so just
like that you get CR you the access to
the data store entity called person and
we should be able to store data and read
data from it okay how many people think
this which is work Wow nobody thanks so
why don't we just go ahead and run it
and I'm use my touch bar there's a
little rum button there which is really
handy and we can actually see and
hopefully run this application yeah and
it just started off in two point seven
two point seven seconds that's I don't
know whatever in my java application
starts really quickly I don't know if
it's going to work so we're going to
find out pretty soon okay
and I'm going to go ahead and use my
IntelliJ IDE here I'm going to go ahead
and create a new go oh yeah I know the
screen is too small so I'll have to
scroll down a little bit
a new HTTP request and I'll call it test
so we're gonna use the curl I can
actually just go to my IDE and maybe do
something like this right so TR p gr
maybe that one so I'm gonna go to my
local host 8080 and then I'm gonna see
if my endpoints up and running and let
me go ahead and run it
and who actually works so I just hit my
local restful service I went to the
person's endpoint I was automatically
generated by spring data and I can see
that I have no data entry in this
service okay pretty cool so why don't we
go ahead and just post some data into it
so I'm going to just write a little
snippet here I'm gonna post to 8080 I'm
gonna post it to the person's endpoint
and for the data here I'm going to let's
see here we have a field called Neum I'm
going to say ray
here that's my name by the way so let's
go ahead and run this post and we will
see what happens so I'm posting to this
service that I just created in about
three minutes and we can already see it
save the data and we also got a primary
URL here with a primary key that we can
we can call so we can just go ahead and
say well let's go ahead and get this as
well and see what is the data inside and
we can see that there are record here
and of course if I go back to persons I
should be able to see now we have one
entry now notice also we have pagination
here so that's really really handy now
if I want to go back to the cow so what
I can do is to go to the data store
console here within my project so I'm
going go find data store because some
people might say wait a second is that
real did that just happen
the only way I can prove this to you
that this actually works is now you can
actually see that we actually have a
data entry there right but of course
this entry could have been there this
whole time you will never know so what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna go back to my
application I'm going to just you know
push drop a little bit more
functionality here okay so I'm going to
go ahead and create a hello world
controller here let me just make sure
yeah I'm gonna say hello and it's gonna
be a rest controller I'm gonna map a URL
here code here code - hello I'm not
passing a name here for the name string
I'm gonna log in I'm gonna return hello
back to whoever it I said hello to me
and I'm just going to go ahead and use
private Bell here to inject the person
repository that I just created now and
what I'm gonna do is in addition to your
saying hello back I'm going to use the
person repository and save the data back
into this right so I'm gonna say name is
equal to name and something like that
okay and hopefully that we just work oh
by the way to simulate that we have in
the multiple services to code each other
because you know it usually don't have
just one service I don't have time to
create two of them today but what I'm
going to do is to just simulate this
whole thing by making another endpoint
that's going to you know ko a few names
here I'm gonna call Mike who is the tio
on the sprinkler GCP project mainly who
is one of my colleagues I first worked
with him and joined cloud Trisha who was
also awesome she contributed a lot to
this project let's say hello to each of
the names I'm going
use the the rest can play client to make
a call to myself to say hello so we can
simulate calling another service right
just cuz I don't have time to write two
of them and so to do this I need to go
ahead and you know of course go ahead
and just make sure we have a rest
template being that we can bootstrap
right all of these are pretty idiomatic
to spring and I need to go ahead and
automatically inject this into my
controller as well so I'm gonna go ahead
and do a private Val rest template and
just inject it here so now I have two
more endpoints that have such hello
which I will save the data I'm gonna say
hello OH which always say hello to three
people and always save each of the data
as well and I'm gonna go ahead and just
restart this application I hope that's
gonna just work as well so I'm gonna
stop it wrong whoo and let me see just
make sure this is actually rebooting
yeah very good
and I'm gonna go back to the test HDTV
here and let's just do a few more things
okay okay I also started pretty quickly
so hopefully this works so when I say
hello to localhost 8080 slash hello
and when I say name is uh next let's do
that and let's run it say hello to next
and of course we get a hollow back right
and remember we also reach we also save
the data and just to show you that this
is actually saving the data now right we
can see this up on the screen in the
data store right and I can also say
hello to you all
so rather than saying hello to just one
person I say hello to all right so it's
gonna iterate through and say hello to
you three different people right and if
we go back to the log we should be able
to see that we say hello to Mike me in
the ng shop and if we go back to the
data store we should be able to see all
of the people I say hello to right so
it's very rapid that you can develop
your application very quickly now so
what's next in the micro services
application architecture if you do have
you know of these services calling each
other
Eco speak OC you cannot need some way to
observe and kind of understand what is
the co stack across all of your services
and to do that you may need to add some
contributed tracing capabilities and
there are a number of libraries out
there you can use like open tracing open
census and you know brave and so on
in spring we have spring cloud sleuth
which can actually a disability tracing
capability to your app now regardless of
whether you deploy your application into
UAE steel environment which can trace
things for you regardless of whether you
do that or you just deploy it in plane
communities or VMs you always need to
propagate the trace ID you always have
to do that in spring cloud sleuth or
where some of these tracing libraries
can capture the trace ID for you and
propagate it for you automatically now
for our demo what we're going to do is
go image that further by adding a
tracing starter here that we created for
sprinkle GCP what this will do is to
build on top of spring cloud sleuth
which is built on top of brave what it
will do is to automatically capture the
trace IDs if not it's going to generate
one for you and it's also going to
automatically propagate it downstream to
the next service code when you're using
rest template and we're also going to
automatically propagate all the traces
in to start or trace okay and we just
done that by adding the starter we don't
have to add any other additional code
the only other thing I might actually
add is the probability of a trace to be
stored by default we only capture 10% of
the traces or the the request will store
the trace for the term longer update to
1.0 which is 100 100 percent so we
casually see everything that's coming
through now in addition to doing this
what I also want to do is to lock my
messages into star driver as well so we
have a logging starter for that what
this will do is to allow you to add log
back configuration fairly easily and you
can then bootstrap your application that
will understand how to log in to start
driver logging and there's a reason why
I'm doing this which I'll show in a
second okay so let me just go ahead and
do this one I'm gonna use this template
for now so what this will do is to lock
the message to the console so I can see
it in SD out but I'm also also going to
log in to star ever I say via the API so
now we have to log appenders it's gonna
split the log message and without
simultaneously send it to both places
okay so let me go ahead and just restart
this app and see if this is oak you know
hooked up properly and hopefully we all
care to see the traces and the log
messages and you have if you
so far there's not so much code right
because spring and spring boot the
framework itself is doing a lot of the
work behind the scenes for you okay so
it's so sorry so let's go ahead and go
back to my test I'm gonna say hello to
Oh now ideally what happened here is
that I triggered this request the trace
ideas generated is propagated downstream
via the rest template to the next call
we have three calls so all of them are
correlated together if I actually go
back to the run if I look at the log now
not only do we see the names if I scroll
left a little bit we can confirm that
here's the trace ID that span across
three different calls and each of the
call is a span it has a spin ID and
they're all being sampled meaning that
they are all being stored into a statue
of a trace okay so what that means is
that if I go here and go to trace and
see the trace list I have this one
additional entry that maybe just came in
yeah there it is and we can see that we
call localhost:8080 stash all we can see
the three different rest template calls
to the remote services which is myself
and we can see how long each of those
take right and furthermore because we
appended the lock we send a law to start
over logging along with the trace ID and
the span ID week actually do this which
is show you correlate logging so because
of this ID tie up I can actually go and
see okay what happened in this band what
kind of error messages came out of it
they're all correlated together which is
really really useful if you are actually
trying to debug some of the production
environment issues okay so that's pretty
much it for my service for now what do
we do next okay let's go ahead and
deploy it into a into a microp analyst
cluster in this case now we have of
course many many ways to deploy this we
can deploy this into App Engine as a jar
in the new App Engine runtime we can
deploy this into cloud run as a
container we can deploy this into
kubernetes whether it has each do or not
it doesn't really matter right so work
is gonna take the lower out of you know
that's deployed is everything into
communities and I'll show you all the
intrinsic details that we have to care
about when we are running a java
application inside of a container okay
so
what we're going to do first is to
continue right so I'm going to talk a
little bit here about continued rising
income can I now spell today continue
right there we go and then we're going
to talk about a little bit about the
library's checks and readiness checks
and we need to talk about how do you
listen to the graceful shutdown events
that is a contract with the urban areas
wrong time or in any like soccer
environments that you actually have a
conversation tool you you want to be
able to shut down gracefully and then
finally we're going to look at
monitoring as well how do you export
metrics from this particular application
so that we can see it from Prometheus
dashboards in this setting and if we
have time we're gonna see how we can
actually debug this application in
production environment in a criminal
environment as well okay so when I
kissed you that hopefully in the next 30
minutes or so so let's let's take care
let's get started
now when you containerize this
application you have to be very careful
I don't know if anyone here right into
this issue where you containerize a java
application running in your kubernetes
cluster or some kind of environment and
then you get this weird message called
outer memory killed all and killed right
a lot of people running through this
issue that is mostly because that the
JVM runtime may or may not understand
how much resource you actually assigned
to your container okay and to take care
of this you actually have to you know
understand which Java version which open
JDK version you're using and what type
of containerized support does it
actually have because after enough what
happened is that the open JDK wrong time
does now actually know how much memory
is being assigned to your container and
the JVM which is used up as much memory
as possible and ultimately you just
gonna get oh and killed in your
application which is be you know
restarting all the time okay so first we
need to go ahead and continue eyes this
application now I can write a docker
file I can write a very simple one but
actually have a separate talk in the
past just for a whole hour on how to
write a proper doctor file that will
contain the highs your java app right
there is a lot of details we have to go
to now lucky enough we do actually now
have a plug-in code ship so if you're
not using Jeep already please please
take a look this is a maven or Gradle
plugin you can just add it to your
beauty
and from here on out I can just use it
to build my container I don't need to
write a docker file you'll actually
follow some of the best practices and
and you don't even need are installed on
your local machine it will just push the
image directly to the remote registry
right so I'm going to go ahead and
create a new image here Cochise your i/o
I'm gonna add my private registry on
Google Cloud right now so I'm gonna use
G cRIO Y square da to seven I'm gonna
push you to the image nyan co-chief demo
for now and I'm going to remember about
the GDK we need to be very careful about
what JDK version that we want to use and
how do you configure that so for me what
I'm gonna do here is to by using a dub
open JDK which has one of the newest
versions of open JDK 8 that actually has
the containerization support you want to
use something that is a update 1 and 1
or higher in order for this to work
properly to have less issues right it's
not at adapt open JDK and going to open
JDK 8 and use the stream image here
instead okay and that's what I need to
do and if I need to here I'm gonna go
open up the the console the terminal and
go ahead and compile this app and turn
this into a container image
ok so I'll do maven wrapper here compile
and Jib build ok so I first need to
compile my app of course and put your
subclasses and then ship is going to do
something telogen it's gonna look at
your maven
beaut file it's going to figure out what
the dependencies are and it's going to
automatically decide how to layer your
darker layers so that the dependencies
goes into its own layer and your app
goes to a separate layer what that means
is that when you're changing on an app a
little bit you're changing a class it
doesn't have to reboot the entire image
you just reboot the layer and push it
out for you automatically and we already
push it to my remote registry and this
is ready to be used
I actually hope this works because that
was also a little bit too fast so I'm
gonna do a darker pork because this is
your remote registry so we can pull this
down and ideally we should be able to
run it ok some God to talk around ti RM
and the name of the image and they
should just spin out my application
and hopefully everything is okay yeah
ooh that's no good
no that's kind of expect it that's fine
we'll fix it later all right so is it
the container runs that's good now you
have the option to put this into your
cloud ROM if you just start up just make
sure you have enough memory for it what
I'm gonna do is to you know just write
this and deploy this into kubernetes
right and then continue my development
cycle in your kubernetes cluster the way
I'm gonna do it is to first I need to
create a new directory where I'm going
to store my deployment manifest with
kubernetes you do write a lot of these
yellow files and manifests to define how
you want to deploy something so I'm
going to do a shortcut here I'm gonna do
chip CTO run my I'm gonna call it demo
service and that the image is the one
that I just created there we go
in my gonna do this use this file called
dry run so what this will do is
naturally not running inside of
kubernetes but it's going to just
simulate it I'm going to see what the
request is gonna be in the yellow format
and I'm going to output it into my KS
directory I'm gonna call it deployment
demo so this is a very quick way for us
to kind of boost rap a deployment file
without having to write the whole thing
manually now there's one thing you do
have to figure out here's to you know
carry out the beta beta one version
because you know it's actually EGA now
so we have u1 and you can see how it
just generated the rest of the files for
me right it's pretty cool now we know
that we have a container that we're
working a containerized environment we
have to deal with communities in the
committee's contracts in terms of how
this application will behave in the
lifecycle what that means is when
application starts there is a lightning
strike that might go off we need to be
able to check whether the application is
still alive right if the application is
not responding to the liveness track
kubernetes will have to restart it and
automatically try to fix this issue the
other thing that we have to watch out
for is the readiness check right in
communities we have two checks life
distractors determines whether
communities need to kill this instance
in restart or not the readiness track is
the one that determines whether the
traffic will be flowing through to my to
my container to my pod right
so we need it's ideal to have both
checks okay you definitely should have
both now the redness track is really
useful in two ways one is that your
application could be a life but it may
not be ready to serve
why because you might need to warm up
the cash we have to make sure all the
connections are established right
everything is ready to go before you
flip the readiness track over and say
give me some traffic the other use case
of it is that when you are shutting down
the application one community is trying
to shut down your java application it's
going to send you a sick term signal
it's a termination signal and you're
supposed to catch it and then do a
graceful shutdown during this whole
process ideally you should turn off the
rate in this check so that you tell
kubernetes
I'm I got the message I'm going to shut
down please don't send me any more
traffic right and and you use that to
tell communities whether you are you
know going to receive traffic or not and
once you have gracefully shut down and
serve oh the invite request you shut
down your application and everything's
fine okay so we're not do both of them
right now for the libraries check the
easiest way to do that is just by you
know adding a simple handler here that
would just respond okay all the time
right so I'm going to say in my life I'm
going to say okay and map it to maybe
slash alive okay that's really easy
easily don't so I just added the
aliveness check here the other thing
that we may want to add is the the
Brittany's track the way that I think
it's pretty awesome thing to do within
the screen ecosystem is actually about
using something called the actuator so
spring has something called the the
spring actuator that will expose a
health check point for you I'm gonna go
ahead and add the actuator actuator
right here it's going to expose a slash
actuator endpoint in with a health
endpoint there that you can actually
plug in and you can use that to kind of
flip yes or no between whatever your
application is ready or not okay and
then there's a there are many different
ways for you to to do a graceful
shutdown the gist here is that you have
to listen for the termination signal in
job by the way you do is by listening to
run time shutdown events and then you
have a separate thread that can
to eight and then that's where you
respond to the shutdown your application
it's actually a really nice module out
there that now can be useful for you
it's a graceful shutdown artifact from
SBB SCH here what that is going to do is
to allow you to replace the how you
start your application so rather than
using the spring boot standard
application I'm going to go ahead and
use grapes will shut down let me see
here a spring application like that yeah
and run and the demo service application
colin colin class java and then all the
arguments from the command line and
that's pretty much it okay and so this
will configure your this particular
module will configure your application
for graceful shutdown and of course you
can do it however other way so you want
but the important thing here is that you
have something like that okay now I'm
ready to you know redeploy this app
again I kind of want to try this one out
where you know I'm developing my
application I'm still adding some
features to it I need to test things out
in your communities not a node or a
cluster but I don't want to do that
rebuild all the time I don't want to do
the cube city or apply all the time one
of the really cool tool that you can use
is called scaffold if you haven't tried
it out this is what it looks like you
can create a new file called scaffold
IMO added to your ID your project here
and I can bootstrap it with just some
content okay and I can carry off just
about everything here I'm going to say
well in scaffold is what it's going to
do so I automatically detect changes in
your source code when you modify
something it's gonna do the
recompilation repeat your application
for you and then deploy to your
communities in this continuous loop okay
so I'm going to go ahead and just make
sure I have the name of the image here
correctly Jib demo and then with the
sorry yeah there we go
and with scalpel I can also just add
what we call the chip maven plug-in here
okay and as you can see down here we
actually automatically detected that we
added the scaffold file and we can
actually configure the application
to run with scaffolding Trinity's just
like that now the reason why this is
happening is because we have this new
tool called the cloud code right so this
is a plug-in you can add to IntelliJ or
vs code and by doing this you can have
you can actually integrate fully with
scaffold and also we have other
capabilities like being able to deploy
this app to app engine and many other
places as well okay so let's go ahead
and just finish up this configuration I
think I can also add arts because all
the time I'm gonna skip tests don't do
this in your own divani environment hey
maybe you do but I only do this for
demos right only yeah of course so go
ahead and run this look what's happened
so I'm going to go ahead and run the the
scaffolding through the IDE so it's
going to go ahead and you know hook up
to my mailing here right and it's gonna
reboot my app and then kick up the
tribute for me and then it's going to
automatically deploy my Yama file from
the Kas the right tree okay I'm gonna
check on time I got 20 minutes yeah so
it's doing a beaut now the 3d of jib is
that it should only change you know
upload layers that's been changed so if
I haven't done a lot of changes this
whole process should be really quick
okay so I have deployed I created my
container and this is actually deployed
into my crop native environment and the
lock that you are seeing right now is
actually coming from cribben at ease
okay this is actually running companies
right now it's just the log is being
streamed into my console and I can show
you what that looks like so for example
if I go to choose DL get pods we should
be able to see them my application is
running okay that's good that's a good
news I can expect that yeah so then what
we can do is to push the I'm gonna
expose an end point so that we can
actually access it you know just so we
know that this is all working so I'm
gonna do the same trick here I'm going
to you exposed and expose the deployment
code demo service the port that we are
going to target is port 8080 we're going
to listen on the port 8080 as well I'm
gonna do a dry run
and I'll put the yellow file I'm going
to output it into ka service mo okay now
skaffa will ideally I'm pretty sure you
will actually pick this up yeah and then
redeploy this file for me so anytime you
make some changes in your source tree
scaffold group will pick up the new
changes and push it to kubernetes and
because of this which you actually have
a new service now that's being provision
code demo service oh one thing I forgot
to do is to make the same so no service
so that we actually get an IP so let me
go in and fix that right so let me go
down here and for the load balancer for
the type Oh where's the type let me do
the type here type I'm gonna say yeah
type is a load balancer let's do that
and that will give us the external IP
address so we can actually test it out
okay so what we done so far
we created the brain in your application
we continue eyes it understanding what
JVM version to use we added live this
track and ready in check we added
graceful shutdown and we're now changing
things now we scaffold so that we can
test this thing out incriminating
hopefully very quickly okay and now we
have added a load balancer with external
IP so I'm just gonna wait for this IP to
become available then we should be able
to see this whole thing in kubernetes
okay not too bad so far right it's okay
yeah alright so the next part of this is
to actually add the deployment modify it
so that we take advantage of the
liveness checks in the rendus checks and
a few things that we have to watch out
for when you want to do a zero downtime
appointment okay so first thing first is
the aliveness probe we already have this
on port 8080 right and we can also ping
it on the path of slash alive right
that's what we put it and then we have
the ravenous probe that is also right
now on port 8080 and the path is
actually actuator slash health okay
now one of the annoying thing that you
have to be careful of is that remember
we added tracing so trace I'm tracing
out 100%
so what that means is every time I get a
health check I'm gonna see a little dot
on my trace list for the Lebanese check
and that's some time not so useful right
so we can actually turn it off in the
liveness probe as well the way we're
gonna do it is by adding the HTTP header
now because we're using smooth behind
these things it uses the what we call
the xp3 headers so we can use the xp3
header code xp3 sampled and we can turn
this value to zero then you will not get
any more traces for this endpoint that's
coming from the liveliest probe this is
actually really useful otherwise you
gonna see a lot of traces that you slide
this probe which may not help you a lot
I know right so now go ahead and save
this and again this is going to kick off
the new deployment there you go and it's
going to apply my changes and so on and
so forth so yeah hopefully that's all
working so let's see if the IP came back
on so it there are they so there's 35 to
2 or whatever I'm going to go ahead and
try it out see if that works ok not bad
yeah ok so we can also see the actuator
right now which is in health and oh look
this is actually down this is cool right
because we have the readiness probe that
we configured remember I change the
deployment files is actually doing a
rolling update so as its doing that
running update is send a sick tempting
though to my existing instance and so my
now my radiance probe is being turned
down ok and kubernetes does take a
couple of seconds to catch up to this
status so that's why the things is still
going through but eventually this thing
will go go out of service and then now
I'm back to the new instance of my my
app with the new configuration ok pretty
pretty awesome now at the same time we
still have to log messages and
everything else that's here now of
course incriminate is when you deploy
something to communities one of the
things you really have to watch out for
regardless of whether it's wrong for App
Engine world communities please do not
write logs to the file system
just please don't do that you know you
either do you STD outs or you write it
to the API and in gke how you
do is to output log as JSON format so
rather than sending it via the API you
can actually do something like this so
I'm going to go ahead and change this
I'm going to use JSON logging instead
log Jason
so by changing out appender we are now
able to log things into Jason messages
and star driver has the agent that can
automatically parse it and get the same
benefits of you know getting the log
levels and the trace IDs and spanner IDs
and everything else okay and as you can
see every time I do something it's gonna
try to reboot my app if you had test
you'll run the test and and would
redeploy this whole thing okay now the
last bits of this is that I really want
to also add monitoring to this right I
want to be able to see how many requests
is coming through how long do the
requests take and the most important
thing in the JVM is how much memory I'm
using in the heap and also potentially
how many threads am i running you know
there are many ways for you to get this
if you have prometheus you can write you
can use a Promethean agent because i'm
in spring what i'm going to do is to use
what we called micro meter which is
another open-source library that's out
there so by adding micrometer like this
with the Prometheus adapter in
conjunction with the actuator what this
will do is to potentially expose your
matrix onto an endpoint code slash
actuator slash Prometheus and if you
actually have this configured then we
can actually scrape the prometheus
metrics and automatically forward out to
start over trace stature of a monitoring
as well and we can actually graph and
plot out all of these different metrics
for you okay so this is what I'm going
to do I'm going to go ahead and you know
just make sure that we have the
management exposure yeah there we go
so we want to expose a hilt endpoint and
the Prometheus output here however when
you do this you gotta be careful because
now anybody who has access to that load
balancer can actually hit these
endpoints right so you're gonna see the
hilt
whether your application up or not you
gotta see your Prometheus stats and
stuff like that so you gotta take care
of you know securing those URL
you can do that within the framework you
can do that via a proxy of some sort or
this one I'm going to do instead I'm
going to go ahead and put my actuator
like this metadata information I'm gonna
put it on a separate port and I'm
putting on port 8081 instead okay so I'm
still serving my application via port
8080 my lightning strike is still on
that port but in my like my readiness
check my Prometheus information that's
all gonna be on the internal port 8081
instead okay so we can definitely do
that right there okay suddenly go ahead
and do that and then of course I have to
go back in here and change how the
radiance probe to 8081 if I want to use
Prometheus to scrape my applications
monitoring metrics there are a number of
ways for you to do it mostly you
probably install a Prometheus operator
in my case I'd using so a bare minimum
version of Prometheus and then we added
a statue of our sidecar to it so that we
can automatically forward that the
monitoring metrics to start up a trace
and for that to happen I do need to add
a few more annotations here some add an
annotation and to tell Prometheus to
actually scrape my endpoints I'm gonna
say Prometheus IO annotation scrape is
equal to true okay and I'm gonna do the
similar thing here we need to know which
port to scrape so it's gonna be 80 81
because that's where the endpoint is and
then finally not do
Prometheus IO a path which is gonna be
actually a tourist path sorry not that
one like that okay so again I'm doing
this in the scaffold davonne loop right
it's going to detect the change in my
deployment it's going to go ahead and
redeploy and now with the annotation
with Prometheus scraping and all that
right we can see how this whole thing
kind of ties up into the end and once my
application comes back up I should still
be able to access my app right and and
then we should be able to go ahead and
go to the monitoring console to see
what's actually there right so let's
let's give it a try not like that so
here we go so here's the endpoint with
the person's I'm going to go ahead and
say hello to Oh again so I'm gonna say
hello oh right and it's gonna go through
this thing with saying
to three people or so I can go back to
my trace I'm gonna turn on auto reload
and ideally I should be able to see the
yeah I can see my traces now this is
actually happening from carbonates
cluster with the logs upward as Jason
and correlated to my tray so everything
works as expected in my community's
environment right and for monitoring
what I can do is then go to start
monitoring because a permit here's all
set up I can go to stat driver
monitoring and I can hopefully use my
matrix for it and I should be able to
find the metrics I want to see okay so
here we can go to resources we can go
ahead and there we go to go to that
matrix Explorer and I should be able to
see communities container yeah not one
and then all of these scrape metrics
it's not going to metrical external
Prometheus Prometheus yeah and then the
suffix of the actual mix race itself so
for example if I want to see the server
requests so I can see request count
where is it right there and we can plot
this out from my application and I can
also group by of course by the name of
the name of the pod okay and as you can
see I really have some other application
running here you can see the metrics
from it because the agent is running
right now which is need some time for
you to catch up right the other thing
that's also very useful is the JVM
metrics I'm gonna say JVM memory and we
can see memory used not one that was
super useful okay and let me go ahead
and group by this and by the name of the
pod and by name of the container as well
now you can really see you can really
see that this is definitely a java
application
right but why what what because because
the B heap is gonna up up up and in this
garbage collection and then you go up
again right but but the good news here
is obviously that it's no memory leaks
right because otherwise you will see
this thing going up all the time and
eventually get om killed right so that's
that's basically how you can get from
this whole thing now the last thing I
want to show you which is really really
awesome is by adding some debugging
agents into your application now what
happens if you are in a pinch really
really need to figure out what happened
to your app why is it not working like
what is this we don't run you cannot
reproduce the issue locally you need to
figure this out right so we can actually
go ahead and add a debugging agents into
this whole thing now we can go back to
the project this is why I'm gonna go
gonna go to source man I'm going to
create a new directory here called [ __ ]
and agents okay so anything you put in
to [ __ ] will get into the container I'm
going to go ahead and copy my agents
from let me see where I put it
Desktop no not that one downloads yeah
agents so I have a few agents here I can
copy into my directory right so now I
have when I beauty in my container I got
these debugging agents I can rely on
that can hook me up to start over
debugging even from a crib in a DC
environment okay
but I do need to make sure that when the
application is starting up I do have the
right startup flags to actually utilize
the agents that we just added right so
here I'm going to add some JVM flags
which will configure the agents for me
so either two agents here about
debugging agent so I can life debug my
application life without stopping the
world and I also added the profiler
agent so I can do production profiling
so I can kind of figure out where the
snow the slowness is kind of happening
right so let me go ahead and save this
and of course strips
sorry scaffold is gonna kicking again
and it's going to review this
application waste hopefully the
debugging agents with the entry point
with the agent arguments are passed in
right it's so very quick that you can
see how this whole tool set cannot hide
up and then deploying it into myopic
into kubernetes cluster
oh my goodness yeah and we can see that
at the startup we can see the agent
actually kicked in so here's the output
from the agent and hopefully my
application starts up fairly quickly
yeah so it's all ready to be used
I hope and then let's go and see what we
can do okay so I'm gonna say let me just
make sure I have this thing Oh hooked up
some guy go to person slash persons yeah
everything's still working good you only
have five minutes left
that's why I keep this to the last right
it doesn't work then thanks for being
here alright so so what we can do then
is this is so cool it's so cool you've
ever seen this before it is so cool so
I'm gonna go back to my console here and
not go to debug so we still trace we
still logging until you I'm gonna go to
profiler so because I added a profiling
agent there I can see my service called
demo service which is the one created I
can see the version which is one I put
into the startup come in line and I can
see the actual flame graph of how much
time CPU time my application is
consuming at different stages right so I
can click into it I can see the flame
chart underneath it so this is a really
nice way to kind of figure out where all
this time is being spent but here's the
other thing that you can do which is
debug this is super cool if you have
your code checking to get if you're
using the get plugins we can actually
automatically check out the code for you
and we can automatically find the source
code okay but in my case because I don't
have the source code uploaded open our
means is that I need to somehow wait for
this UI to come back up in which case I
should be able to see my service that's
listed here oh thank you nice it still
works alright so so somehow over here
after some runtime I should be able to
see my application that I just deployed
I don't see it yet so we'll need to wait
a little bit for a to to come back up
right so let me just make sure my app is
still there yeah okay good good good
yeah so eventually just saw coming and
what I can do is to browse through this
you I hopefully find the application I'm
trying to debug and then from there I
can actually just start adding these
snapshot points then I can capture the
state of my application as the lines
going through the code and I don't know
if this ever happened to you when you're
trying to debug something and you you
see the log messages and then you say oh
no I wish I have one more log what do
you do you go back check out the log
check out the the application check out
the write revision of the app and then
what and then you know check it backing
you know go through the hardy point read
appointment of some sort in the bypass a
lot of processes and stuff like that I
don't know it's trying to get to
production so you can actually get that
log message with a debugging agent you
can actually do that directly from the
console provided that you do have the
right access to do that so let me see if
this is what this actually came back
hopefully hopefully it's there oh there
this alright so now you can see that my
application register itself with a
debugging console here so we can see
demo servers with the version zero point
zero point one I have no source code so
I can go ahead and upload it if I want
to I can also do this from the IDE as
well if I want to but right now I'm just
going to go ahead and upload my source
code in the continent so this actually
works with Java and kahlan code right
now as well okay and I'm gonna go back
to this place right here I can see my
source code all right and I can add a
snapshot point anywhere so I can say I
wonder if what's happening here again
provided you have the right permission
to do it you can say I wonder what is
happening on this line of code and if I
come back here if I say hello now watch
very carefully when I say name is Ray
again I guess right
watch carefully on the right hand side
hopefully oh well somebody hit it first
great talk thank you
that's that's awesome
in case you don't want those messages
well I love this message but in case you
want to capture everything you can also
add conditions here right so you can
based on the condition of what you want
to capture but thank you very much for
whoever that sent this first thing in so
we can see the values you can also see
the co stack but so here's the thing
here's my my favorite part of this whole
thing which is the login part right and
somebody told me about this is called
binary debugging with logs what does
that mean
it is what we usually do right we add a
lock message at first at the beginning
say I'm here and then you add a message
at the very end to say it works if it
doesn't get - it works
that means the port somewhere in the
middle then you add a message in the
middle somewhere
maybe it work here right and every time
you do this we actually output a lot for
you into the lock messages we should be
able to see it in the log here so if I
do another refresh and you know when the
logs and come through we should be able
to see this being produced directly in
your production environment if you have
the right process and permission to do
it okay so with though I said I think we
did a lot in the past 50 minutes
hopefully it was very useful for you as
well to kind of get a feel of what it's
like to develop applications on Google
cloud with framework support with all
the tooling that we have in IDE in the
plugins and with other things like
scaffolding jib
if you want to learn more this is the
last line I'm going to get to which is
we have quite a few resources you can go
to you can try a lot of things that we
try to show you in the loan collab if
you want to learn more about spring and
spring cloud GCP you can go to our short
collapse there we also have Coursera
courses we got great great documentation
and if you want to get in contact with
me you can find me on Twitter or come to
my site and find more information so
thank you so much for being here I
really really appreciate it thank you
[Applause]
[Music]